oh I don't know what was happening there
but it's it's genius I mean I look like
I'm having a good time
huge jacket I don't know what that was
about maybe that was like sort of an 80s
thing me and Downey and Richard loved it
he's tucked away back there I'm wearing
a whole bunch of necklaces and I don't
know what's on my shirt I got something
hanging on my belt but maybe my keys my
shirt is tucked into my pants
man I don't know but I needed a lot of
help there looks like I'm wearing a oh
yeah very skinny belt
well there is a collar I just look
confused completely by the outfit I love
this trenchcoat deal I think the Hat is
the law firm that used to represent me
and they gave me a hat handsome Jacobsen
Toberman and Teller is the name of the
company I'm Brad Pitt he had any nick
style all which was fantastic he looked
great I'm wearing my big cowboy belts
and pants that go up to here is that
amazing oh my god
this must have been for the opening
night of cuffs I think I know where this
isn't my outfit so I was doing the
sunglass thing there you really can see
a difference between this and the
oversized pants and jackets that I was
wearing these this is like starting to
become a little bit more style conscious
you